good to see you Frank Caliendo good to
see you great to be here good for
getting my impressions and who they are
it's okay I actually did forget like
people might think that was a bit but I
want to come clean I want to be honest
that's all about trustworthiness and the
media yeah and I was over there I
thought I was doing the jaws impression
but I was doing the bill while I was so
glad that you knew I we have to walk I
didn't know who am i doing right now
what am I talking about and that's it's
so close I truly
[Music]
this could be and jaws is to it that's
where that that and and and and shefter
you make me maybe walk this could
possibly be one of the most important
segments in the history of society if in
fact rotation of the earth seems to be
keeping in orbit and we know that with
the theory of the Big Bang
it all started from nothing a lot like
this report well you know they
discovered a black hole there did you
see that on Twitter today they show
today yesterday they [ __ ] like
literally were able to photograph a
black hole yeah there's time so it's
just out of the blue all of a sudden we
got it they've been working on it for
the last 10 days back from the dark so
this was the big day reveal and Magic
Johnson
Magic Johnson Eclipse all news so how
would how has Charles Barkley told you
know in the NBA right now and this is
crazy
if the Western Conference is more do
Bron James coming into the Western
Conference it's a it's a difficult
situation right first of all but they
look inside the Lakers Gina bus and
she's trying to drive it to drive the
bus what a terrible pun that was but I
enjoyed myself
look at if you're magic this is a trick
that's all I can say it's a magic trick
that's what I think it is magic still
gonna be trying to woo people to the
Lakers yeah but now I can and that's
very important that is very important
before important I like that used you
shorten you shorten small shortened
words yeah a little bit he does that for
important and then say them over and
over did Stephen H Smith was there last
night I don't even understand what's
going on in this world it's the ecliptic
nation of what I've just seen I never
thought in the full perpetuity that it
ever would and capsule
the veracity of contemplation henceforth
we understand vertically that there is
something going on and you know who's
gonna be taking over and you know who
said it who's that you know who's gonna
take over for the Lakers Lavar ball
Lavar ball he said it he said it months
ago that this is what was going to
happen
Lavar ball the soup say by the way that
that is I love Stephen a that is a
Stephen a staple is to say that it's
been going on for months
the minute it finally does happen they
have known about Magic Johnson's going
to be walking away since they started
studying that black hole years ago
before any of this even happen it's
breaking the space-time continuum rich
everyone knows that there's a multi
plasma tude of universal perpetration
Frank Kelly I know here in the Rich
Eisen show the camera I keep thinking
ray Donovan's doing the camera which is
he also knows the right people so be
careful I'm a fixer he's a physics and
and it looks like Luke's job might be
saved I I don't know how would Bill
Walton
easy you're going the right way this is
a young man who came up a difficult
upbringing look at who his parents were
this is so hard but a wonderful child
understanding the world getting to see
it from the inside out
this is how I'm wearing my shirt right
now I should pay more attention when I'm
getting dressed and the truth is when
you look at everything you have to
realize the truth supersedes all like
him and Steven Naismith in perpetuity
and in graciousness just throwing words
out one after another I think is going
to be a new bit well in terms there you
go in terms of an end because I love
honing this stuff with you in terms I
like to think
shows a workshop it's it's absolutely
fun you want to come here and work on
some stuff yeah it's another one of the
voices that you do who's a polysyllabic
guy is wrong Roma oh you know I'm only
there usually three or four like fair
nah man no incredible ridiculous
ridiculous
broccoli rock or Greek philosophers
Aristotle I crack myself up
how much am i cracking myself up right
Marius Rome great take incredible job
maybe right now you're summoning the
powers of Rome how great is that does
not get any better than what just
happened the problem is whenever I'm on
the show and a guest of rich he never
gets a chance to ask a question I just
start taking over claiming that members
of his crew are stars on other shows why
we ray Donovan a fictional character
come on the Rich Eisen show and run a
camera that's running cameras bad take
good job but just what if your rate
Donovan you've got a lot of Hollywood
fixing to do maybe start up a bar in
Boston with your brother so where's
always in trouble
Mick dude what is up with Mick and to
beginning of the show I didn't think he
fit in but then watching what went on he
became my favorite thing to look forward
to it just not get any better than an
old Irish guy who loves bad things and
he's been to prison Nick
working the camera right here has
spurred on a Jim Rome recounting of the
plot lines of rape so let me let me turn
this one tease now who Frank Caliendo
out of
of your of your voices breathing more
you or me during that whole that's more
energy than no chance you you texted me
after the last time you came on after
mooch did go on the air and about muchas
yes you're like you saw you oh you said
he is that old Chris Farley going on
he really does I think my favorite text
view is like during if this is the one
time you didn't text me back at all busy
on the air yeah usually you text me back
quite not right away but no commercial
breaks or wild Kurt Warner's talking and
he's a good guy just I don't know no I
did a charity for him never doing one
again for him no he's great fantastic
credible guy family is all great but uh
you were doing the NFL you're doing the
NFL Draft and I'm like I'm gonna come
there and help you fill time next time
nothing back like no this was a free
Frank I'm sure I was just busy without
hick number 235 or so that's right
that's where it's like fun because I
know I'd love that like you look over to
Gruden and then we can actually voice
over and right now man I like that guy
I've only got 12 quarterbacks that
picked so far gonna ask you I mean why
is Gruden kicking the tires and Kyle
Amari in all those cord-like little guys
man like if I could like a trap to
Smurfs I'd do it snow white man grumpy
or is that a smurf man how about angry I
like it angry quarterback he's got a
chip on his shoulder man sneezy stay
away don't
we're not drafting sneezy Cuyler I think
he's another one man like Cuyler he's
pretty good out there in Oklahoma man
just tremendous job so that's why
Gruden's out there make a well he's got
a quarterback in car I want to do multi
quarterback formations man we're gonna
we're gonna trade for it we're gonna
trade for uh
Russell Wilson yeah how'd I forget that
that's two names of athletic apparel man
we're gonna get him man will get Kyler
Murray Steve time who lives down there I
live on the same street yes as the
general manager of the Cardinals well no
he lives that he lives a little bit of a
ways away I live on the same street as
the Cardinals training facility so I
live right there and I'll pop over there
every once in a while but and Steve came
and I become friends actually through
Lancer line who's NFL Network has - your
line coach there and together Jews can
you break news yeah I texted Steve and
he probably doesn't want to break this
news I told him I was gonna look at your
phone I want to get this accurately
Frank alien is about to break news here
in the recharge
there today from Steve's from Steve
crime hmm I think this is real we don't
do fake news here hmm I'm going to trade
the first pick for Tom Brady and Gronk
is gonna come out of retirement didn't
play for us since he went to Arizona and
loves it in the desert I think that's
real real problem Steve calm I can
verify that we're breaking news another
voice no shifters gonna give me to
confirm it this seems to be something
and has actually been texted to Frank
Caliendo from Steve crime but we're
looking into verification hey this is
Jay Glazer mr. pappan is your first
against yeah I don't believe this I was
working out a few minutes ago I like to
work out between workouts here 40 you
ever do that work out between to work
out you get plucked up I've seen that
with the rock I don't like to drop names
come on ballers come on ballers I
actually taught the rock how to raise
the eyebrows that me it's just too flat
to flat eyebrows or to raise eyebrows
that's like don't do one or the other
that's what you think that's a great we
do that you see where she knocked out my
tooth
it's incredible to Cocker she punch it
right out of it yeah yeah with Viral I'm
not trying to make it go viral again but
if it does go viral but it's pretty
essentially what it should be but yeah
so one time time time it texted because
they eat these guys don't know each
other so well and Gruden I texted Groody
something that I was coaching Steve's
son flag football yeah and I don't know
what I can legally say on the air but
this was Gruden's reply it was just one
line he's not your son he's not gonna
win it he's not gonna win an effing game
and where he was right we didn't propose
to I think Joey Bosa on the show Joey
did was that real it was that an April
Fool's joke I don't know yeah I try I
trade drafting for
nations with Steve time for Monterey
nose meatballs your mother no I have not
yeah this is worthy of the draft some
believe how would Madden respond to all
this your day today it's not you know
that we can let's make it topical so I
actually lived in the time but all they
needed was Brett Favre and then you
don't have to worry he's on the Iron
Throne back to 83 today 83 I told you
know follow my Instagram if Madden if
you had to choose any Game of Thrones
character formatting it would have to be
either Hodor or the mountain right
that's the tie I think it's he's
carrying around far farva's bran stark
that's gonna be next time next time
coming back next week we do the next
like I said any time and the Brea improv
on April 14th Houston improv on the 18th
of April Richfield Playhouse in
Richville Connecticut
rounds out your April schedule on the
28th the Irvine improv on the 2nd
Chicago get ready for Frank on May 16th
and then upstate New York it's the
Niagara Falls on the 17th so on and so
forth at Frank Caliendo an Instagram I'm
upping my Instagram game as you speak
because I've neglected it so much but at
Frank Caliendo on Instagram if you can't
spell calendar it's a letter see the
word alien and the word do so at Frank C
alien do and all those dates you
mentioned at Frank on stage calm you go
fantastic Thomas is coming in our number
three our number three were there Oh
Thomas that's that still it comes from
end Asst four more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app